あの簡単に時間があまりありませんので
簡単に概況で結構ですけど
今日の講義とちょっと関連した長老の著書の中で疑問に思った点があるのでご相談したいのですが
著書の中の一言 1 日 2言の中でですね
釈迦の釈迦が仏陀のお釈迦様のおっしゃった言葉で
出家の方は修行しなさい
修行しなさい そして在家の方は在家を気づきなさいという在家の方は財産を築きなさいという説明の言葉があって
それを長老がご説明されているのですが
その説明がもう一つですね
なんか財を築くというのは
あまり常識的な考えではそうなのかもわかんないんですけど
なんか釈迦の言葉としてはちょっともう一つ納得いかないような感じがしたんで
なるほど あ じゃあ在家の人は仕事をしないでこじきで生活しますかね
そういう意味じゃないんですけど
在家の人も修行しなさいということですか？ いえ
仕事を誰もしますよ 人間なら
生命なら仕事をして生きているんです
それは論理なんです 何もしないで生きることはできないんです
犬も猫も仕事をしていますよ
鳥たちも仕事をしているんです
赤ちゃんも仕事をしていますよ
だから我々喜んで赤ちゃんの面倒を見てあげる
だから そのその生命に適した仕事があります
それをやれば幸福に生きていられます
で カラスはもう怠けてじっと寝ていちゃうと死んでしまっちゃいますよ
だからさっさと動いて生活しています
だからそれはもう生命の法則であって
誰も誰でも自分にある仕事は必ずやらなくちゃいけない
そういうことだから 出家は金儲けはやるなよ
出家には出家の仕事があります
そこで田んぼを作ったり
野菜を作たり 商売やったりするのは
これは在家の妻帯持っている人々の日常生活です
それには何も別にそれぐらいのことだと思います
言葉で言葉でですね あえてなんか在家の人は財を築きなさいという言葉
あります あります  それがもう一つですね
なんかしっくり来ないです
しっくり来ていないというか
だから金財産を作ることって悪いと思ってます？ 悪いとは言わないんですが
積極的に言うような言葉ではないんじゃないかなとは思います
だからブッダだからそれ積極的に言うんで
ブッダが言わないだろうと思ってるんだから
みんな ブッダはもう全部欲を捨てなさい
解脱に達しなさい そればっかりワンカラーでね
1色で同じこと言ってると思ったら大勘違いで
もう夫婦は仲良くするためにどうするのかと思うまで
何でもかんでも質問されたら言うんです
だからお釈迦様質問されたんですよ
人々は 私たちは在家で
在家としてもう楽に生活もしたいし
だからで死んで地獄には行きたくないんだよと
何か方法はあるのかと
ありますよと だったらちゃんと正しく財を設けて
正しく使って 家族やら友人やらみんなの面倒を見てあげて
それから心を罪を犯さないで生活すれば
もう今世もあなた幸福やと
死んだら天国に行くんだよという
いえ 何となくではなくて
これは年寄りで仕事をできなくなると
子供たちが面倒見なくちゃいけないんですよ
で それでない限りはもう何かしなきゃダメなんです
それ仕事なんです で 必ず
例えば年寄りも仕事をしても
別に金なくて ただボランティアでやってもいいんです
それでも自分には収入あるんですよ
良いことをしているという
若い時はやっぱり世間を養わなくちゃいけないんだからね
わかりました はい あと一つぐらい質問できると
どうぞ その方 はい どうぞ
私 過去に仕事で悪いことをしてしまったことがあるんですけども
その時のことがいつも頭をよぎってしまってあるんですけど
なかなか消えないんですけど
それは修行で解決できないからでしょうか
人は誰でも悪いことしますよ
悪いことしない人間っているわけないでしょ
悪いことしなかった人間っていうのはね
大体悪いとわかっているのは後なんですよ
だからこの問題 誰にでも同じな
過去を考えたら あれも失敗しました
あれも悪かった これも悪かったとかね
いくらでもありますよ
やっている時は悪いと思わないしね
しかし それを思い出すたびに
自分がその罪を改めるんですよ
過去で一回悪いことしたんですけど
これは 1万回思い出して悩んだりすると
1万回悪いことしたことになるんです
だから忘れた方がいいんです
もう無罪になっているんだと
わかりました うん 過去のことだからもう関係ないんだと
あまり思い出したらいかん
はい  他の方よろしいでしょうか
はい では新年の祝福の新年というか
なんか分かりません 私はこの年末のキリスト教の世界だから
で 合掌してください  ジャヤントーボーディアモーレサッキャナンナンディヴァンダナ
エーワントイハンジャヨトゥジャヤッスジャヤマンガラン
ナッティメーサラナンアニャンブッドメーサラナンワラン
エーテーナサッチワンジェーナホトゥテージャイマンガラン
ナッティメーサラナンアニャンダンメーサラナンワラン
ナッティメーサラナンアニャンサンローメーサラナンワラン
エーテーナサッチワンジェーナホトゥテージャイマンガラン
サッビーティヨーヴィワンジャントゥサッバローゴーヴィナッセトゥ
マーテーバヴァンワンテラーヨーสุขィディーガーユコーバヴァ
バヴァトゥサッバマンガランランカントゥサッバデーヴァター
サッバブッダヌーバーヴェーナ
サッバダンマヌーバーヴェーナ
サッバサンガヌーバーヴェーナ
サダースンティーバヴァントゥテー
アビワダナシーリスサニッチャンワンダパチャイノー
チャンダローダンマヴァンダンティアーユワンノースカンバラン
アーユラーローギャサンパッティサンガサンパッティメーウェッチャ
アトローニッバーナサンパッティイミナーテーサミンジェトゥ
サーミンサーミンサーミン
はい では終了いたします
どうもありがとうございました
ありがとうございます